cdc director dr rochelle walinski joins
us now good morning to you dr wolinski
we got a lot to sort out this morning we
heard the president say one thing and
you seemed good morning to you if we
could call it a good morning there's a
lot going on in these coveted streets
you know we heard the president say one
thing about we we didn't see this coming
we we heard you seem to say that yeah we
sort of knew so if we knew that this was
coming why are we not better prepared
the lines are very long you can't get a
home test these days what happened
yeah
yeah good morning gail um so things are
moving quickly right so um about a week
ago we reported that we had about three
percent of our sequences now
representing omicron and now this week
we're reporting up to 73 so we've found
we've known about omicron for a little
less than a month now
and as we've been following it for the
last several weeks we have seen in
countries that preceded us in other
places doubling times of this virus of
as quickly as two days or one and a half
days even so as we started to learn
about this just over the last couple of
weeks we have seen that what is
happening here in the united states has
mirrored what is happening in the in
other countries and that really was the
motivation for the president's um and
the administration's work right now to
increase surge capacity throughout
hospitals to increase capacity to do
testing and access to testing and then
of course to increase access to
vaccinations as well i know we've heard
all that we need to do and clearly
people are not doing it but i still want
to go back to it doesn't seem like we
were prepared for this
yet you know the administration has been
doing a lot in testing and we have a lot
more work to do we recognize that we've
invested three billion dollars in rapid
tests
and even yesterday the president
announced another 500 000 rapid tests
that will be distributed to
people without otherwise having access
we have 20 000 sites that you can get a
free pcr test and even right now as we
speak we're scaling up rapid
pcr testing federally federal sites for
pcr testing
in places that have the highest demand
including new york
dr wolinski with all of these people
testing positive these days and more
positives expected in january people are
looking at that 10-day isolation period
that's still in effect even if you're
vaccinated and boosted meanwhile the uk
has reduced it to seven days delta co
wants a reduction here we've heard one
of our frequent guests dr ashish jah say
to friends he recommends as little as
five days could we see movement from the
cdc on that quarantine period
yeah it's a great question we're
actively examining those data now and
i'm doing some modeling analyses to
assess that and we anticipate that we'll
have some updates soon
dr wolinski more than a thousand
children have died of covert in the u.s
they currently make up a quarter of the
cases 90 of children aren't vaccinated
so a lot of parents like myself are
trying to figure out how to navigate not
just through the holidays but also with
school so what do you think we should do
should we gather with our friends and
family and do you believe schools should
be shut down
right so several things in there nate
first the best way we can protect our
children is to get them vaccinated
children above the age of five are all
eligible for vaccination and we are
really working to get our children
vaccinated to protect them from disease
if your child is less than five the best
way to protect them is to surround them
with people who are vaccinated
themselves who are boosted themselves in
terms of the holiday how do we do the
holidays safely certainly you want to
make sure that you're vaccinated and
boosted if you're eligible and that the
people who you're gathering with are
vaccinated and eligible as well but i
want to highlight one important piece
and that is people are talking about the
plane rides and the train rides and
that's actually not where
where the real challenge is how safe
your holiday is is really about how safe
you are in the time leading up to the
holiday yeah we all have the information
it's just a matter of what we do with
the information you've certainly put the
message out there thank you dr richelle
wilinski we'll see you again i know
thank you so much
indeed